hero or villain the final frames of I Am
Legend see Dr Robert Neville as Humanity
savior but the alternate ending paints a
completely different picture and it's
one the film's director was hoping to
show in theaters the alternate ending
many of us first saw when the DVD was
released was actually intended to be the
original ending to I Am Legend after
audiences responded poorly to the
ambiguous original ending during test
screenings however it was scrapped and
replaced with the theatrical version as
director Francis Lawrence told Screen
Rant we tested it twice and it got
wildly rejected wildly rejected which is
why we came out with the other one
audiences wanted an ending that painted
Neville as a genuine hero not a morally
ambiguous scientist so they did last
minute re-shoot for a more conventional
and flashy Hollywood ending in the
theatrical cut after realizing his last
experiment worked and the test subject's
condition was improving Neville draws
the dark secret blood and gives the
sample to Anna telling her the Cure is
in the blood Neville shows Anna and
Ethan a place where they can hide and
tells them to leave Manhattan at Sunrise
Neville grabs a hand grenade stashed in
a drawer and sacrifices himself in a
blaze of glory to protect Anna Ethan and
the Cure he worked tirelessly on for the
last 3 years when Anna and Ethan arrive
at the Survivor colony in Vermont she
passes the cure to a guard dressed in
military fatigues with voiceover
celebrating his Discovery and at
8852 he gave his life to defend
it we are his
legacy the theatrical cut and the
director's cut with the alternate ending
are essentially the same until the last
5 minutes of the film the climax of both
versions begins in Neville's laboratory
when Neville sees a butterfly pattern in
broken glass which reminds him of his
daughter Marley from shortly before she
died in the theatrical version when
Neville turns to look at Anna and Ethan
crouched against the back wall he
notices a butterfly tattooed on Anna's
neck as she cradles Ethan trying to
protect him from the frightening
onslaught of dark Seekers Neville
decides this butterfly is a sign and
gives Anna the blood sample believing
his job is to protect her so she can get
it to the survivors colony in Vermont
the dark Seekers are nothing more than
mindless hunting machines driven by base
instincts and blood lust in the
alternate ending however Neville
realized the alpha male is trying to
communicate with him he realizes that
the dark Seekers have become violent and
attacked his home because he kidnapped
the alpha male's mate this information
suggests that the dark Seekers are more
than just thoughtless creatures but that
they have familial bonds and a social
structure as well all this information
shatters Neville's perception of the
world and he quickly realizes he needs a
new approach to dealing with his former
enemies once Neville understands the
dark Seekers are sensient beings he puts
puts down his firearm and takes his test
subject the alpha female out of the
protected room at the back of his
Subterranean laboratory and into the
Open Lab where the dark Seekers wait
although the alpha male is menacing
roaring in Neville's ear to show his
anger the dark Seekers allow Neville to
walk into the lab while pushing the
gurnie the alpha female is lying on now
realizing the dark Seekers are sensient
he brings the alpha female out of
sedation with a shot and gives her back
to the alpha male without drawing her
blood to make a cure for the cryppin
virus or KV the tender way the alpha
male picks up the alpha female and the
way she nuzzles him illustrates that the
dark Seekers not only have a social
structure they have feelings they
experience love pain and anger like the
humans they once were distraught Neville
apologizes to the dark Seekers with an
expression that clearly reveals the
depths of his regrets I'm
sorry the alternate ending of I Am
Legend while different from its source
material is true to the spirit of
Richard mat's thought-provoking 1954
sci-fi Nolla of the same name in the
alternate ending the dark Seekers allow
Neville to live leaving him in his
destroyed laboratory to ponder his
crimes as Neville leans against the
glass door separating him from Anna and
Ethan the camera cuts to the wall
covered with pictures of Neville's test
subjects in the background the camera
focuses on Neville as we see the
understanding that he has committed a
atrocities settle upon his face as a
former Soldier and scientist Neville
understands just how grave his
violations against the dark Seekers were
in the theatrical cut Neville never
makes this vital realization and he dies
believing he is a hero who found and
protected the cure for KV from the
monsters in their midst in the alternate
ending it Dawns on Neville that he is
effectively the dark seeker's Boogyman a
mad scientist who hunts and kills them
unaware their humanity is intact despite
the the physical transformation the
krippin virus elicited this was the
point of mathison's Nolla and the reason
for its enigmatic title the theatrical
ending is a severe misrepresentation of
the nolla's message about discrimination
and how people dehumanize others so they
can mistreat them without experiencing
guilt for their actions attitudes and
crimes against
humanity the alternate ending of I Am
Legend introduces an unexplored
Dimension to the story offering a Twist
that fundamentally shifts the a his
perception of the protagonist Neville it
reveals that the dark Seekers have loved
ones among them highlighting the moral
ambiguity of Neville's actions while
Neville initially sees himself as a
scientist working to find a cure for the
virus that had devastated Humanity the
dark Seekers certainly view him as the
embodiment of their worst nightmares
notably they never actively hunt Neville
until he kidnaps the Alpha's mate
throughout the movie Neville pursues two
main objectives searching for other
surviving humans and seeking a cure for
the virus if there's anybody out
there
anybody please Neville's character takes
a darker turn when his loyal dog Sam
gets infected in a fit of rage he goes
on a violent Rampage using his car to
kill dark Seekers indiscriminately the
phrase I Am Legend originates from the
book serving as Neville's last words
when he realizes how the dark Seekers
will remember him for atrocities such as
is this Beyond simply being a proper
representation of Richard mat's original
story the alternate ending of I Am
Legend is the only ending that really
makes sense because there is evidence of
the Dark Seeker sentients breadcrumbed
throughout the film for instance the
alpha male briefly steps into the light
after Neville kidnaps his mate using a
snare suggesting the alpha male wanted
to rescue her from Neville but knew it
could not leave the safety of Darkness
later in the film Neville is trapped in
a similar snare baited with a mannequin
Neville placed outside the video store
to simulate life this prevents Neville
from leaving the area Before Sunset so
the alpha male can sick infected dogs on
him and Sam in a vicious but calculated
Act of Revenge in the theatrical cut we
could view this interlude as evidence of
other survivors playing with Neville
however the alternate ending makes it
clear trapping Neville and ambushing him
is proof of the alpha male's intellect
the theatrical ending ignores these
hints in the service of creating a more
conventional climax with an
inspirational and uplifting ending about
an unambiguous hero who sacrificed
himself for Humanity the Nuance of the
alternate ending might not be as
satisfying for audiences who want Heroes
and happy endings but it was certainly
more thought-provoking and true to the
mood of the first hour of the film and
the Nolla in the alternate ending
Neville doesn't go out in a blaze of
glory to protect the Cure he gave to
Anna and Ethan as he does in the
theatrical version instead Neville
leaves Manhattan with no cure in hand
his research abandoned while he stews in
the knowledge of his unethical treatment
of dark Seekers during his desperate
search for a cure to KV Neville Anna and
Ethan drive away from Manhattan together
searching for the proped survivors
colony in Vermont when his wife and
daughter die during the catastrophic
evacuation of Manhattan Neville puts all
of his hope and belief in a future for
Humanity into finding a cure Neville is
so focused on a cure he can't see the
dark Seekers clearly for this reason
he's not relieved to discover there are
other survivors like Anna and Ethan but
instead frustrated to discover that his
belief that he is Humanity's Last Hope
has been false the whole time social de
Evolution appears
complete typical human behavior is now
entirely
absent another important piece of the
alternate ending is that it does not
conclude that Neville Anna and Ethan
find the survivors colony in Vermont as
the theatrical version verion does
instead as they drive out of the city a
new radio transmission plays in the
background assuring listeners they're
not alone I'm traveling with Dr Robert
Neville and a boy named
Ethan we're heading north on Route 177
to bethl Vermont this alternate ending
is open-ended and doesn't promise a
happy ending when they reach Vermont the
future is not written there is no cure
but Neville Anna and Ethan are alive
they are together and there is hope that
there are others out there who have also
survived it's not as definitive flashy
or clean as the theatrical cut but it's
a lot more realistic much like life one
chapter ends and another begins without
the clarity of knowing what's in store
according to a 2014 interview with money
into light in an earlier version of the
script Neville's loyal companion Sam met
a different fate one of the saddest
moments in the film occurs when Sam
valiantly fights off The Dark Secret
dogs to save Neville but but gets bitten
and infected in the process Neville is
then forced to make the heart-wrenching
decision to euthanize Sam however in an
earlier draft of the script Sam had a
different storyline in writer Mark
protosevich early version of the script
Sam is an unnamed male dog who gets
infected by the dark Seekers however
instead of Neville euthanizing his dog
he decides to release him later on in
the climax Neville and his infected dog
run into each other as Neville leads
human Survivor to appear the dog
initially joins the Dark Seeker dogs in
hunting them but eventually decides to
return the favor once he recognizes his
former Master this earlier script
version would have aligned more closely
with the original concept of the story
where the dark Seekers are not just
Mindless zombies but instead an
intelligent species capable of forming
emotional connections like many book
adaptations before it I Am Legend is
certainly guilty of not being entirely
faithful to its 1954 Source material
in mat's book Robert Neville is not the
sole survivor there are a group of
survivors living together what's more
the dark Seekers aren't visually
frightening humanoid creatures they can
actually visually blend in with humans
this contrast makes for a more nuanced
exploration of bigotry and
discrimination in the book the new
arrival in the community is named Ruth
not Anna after getting involved with
Ruth Robert learns she is one of the
infected and she was sent as a spy to
infil and undermine the Survivor colony
from the inside Robert learns he killed
her husband during his experiments as he
dies from a wound Robert uses his last
breath to mutter I Am Legend knowing he
will be remembered for his crimes
against the infected in hindsight
director Francis Lawrence thinks
audiences may have related to the film
just as much if they'd followed the
nolla's plot more closely he explained
the Screen Rant they would have accepted
the nihilistic ending they would have
accepted vampires instead of people with
infection sections we could have
literally made the book which I would
have been much happier with in his
Screen Rant interview director Francis
Lawrence admitted that he preferred his
original ending to the theatrical cut as
it sent more of a thoughtful message
than the alternative however he also
conceded that going with the alternative
ending wouldn't be the most strategic
move for a blockbuster saying in terms
of story math we doing everything you're
not supposed to do right the hero
doesn't find the Cure right
it seems that after the openly negative
reaction audiences gave at test
screenings Lawrence made the executive
decision to sacrifice his own
preferences for the sake of the Public's
enjoyment unfortunately that's not the
only regret he has about the film he
told den of geek that he had originally
wanted to do the dark Seekers with
practical makeup effects but turned to
CGI due to time constraints and
problematic test shoots in his mind the
movie felt relatively unfinished by the
time it screened he explained
having done a movie with so many visual
effect shots and then coming to the end
where you have the plug pulled because
you have a deadline and you have to
deliver the last reel and you know
there's a hundred shots in the movie
you're not satisfied with was a real
disappointment to me thanks to the
commercial success of I Am Legend Warner
Brothers contemplated a sequel to cash
in on the popularity of the film there
were a few ways this could have gone
while the alternate ending left the door
wide open for a direct sequel Neville's
death in the theat electrical cut made a
prequel seem like the obvious choice in
2008 Will Smith confirmed this telling
collider the studio had the idea for a
prequel that depicted The Last Stand of
Manhattan presumably before Humanity was
all but wiped out in a similar fashion
to the Planet of the Apes reboot by 2011
however Francis Lawrence told MTV that
the prequel was effectively never going
to happen in 2018 Lawrence doubled down
telling Screen Rant he had lost the urge
to do another IM am leg Legend movie in
2022 however Lawrence confirmed to comic
book that there had been talks about
Reviving the sequel unfortunately that's
all he could say about it as he also
told the outlet those conversations are
confidential for the time being if you
take Lawrence's word for it it may be a
while yet before serious efforts go into
the sequel's production for in the same
interview he also confirmed he's working
on Constantine 2 however AKA goldsman
who co-wrote the 2007 screenplay had
some slightly different news for
deadline not only did he confirm that he
was working on sequels to I Am Legend
and Constantine he said that the new I
Am Legend movie would pick up from the
alternate ending he credited the HBO hit
series The Last of Us as the inspiration
to take another look at the
post-apocalyptic
franchise Will Smith has become well
known for his meticulous selection of
film projects especially when it comes
to sequels his involvement alone could
secure financing an audience interest in
a movie upon the release of I Am Legend
the film achieved the typical financial
success and positive critical reception
associated with Smith's other projects
from the 2000s consequently discussions
about a sequel commenced despite Smith's
character meeting his demise in the
original initially variety reported that
the concept revolved around Game of
Thrones co-creator DB y scripting a
prequel involving the Last Stand that
Smith had described poer however this
idea faced delays until it was
ultimately scrapped the potential sequel
that goldsman discussed with deadline
would instead follow Neville after his
survival in the alternate climax Goldman
explained that his vision for the film
took place several decades after the
events of the original so it will be
particularly interesting to see how
Neville is holding up in the years since
he stopped looking for a cure much like
Lawrence Will Smith's approach to an i
IM Legend the sequel has evolved over
the years in 2012 he expressed
reluctance about appearing in another I
Am Legend movie during an interview with
the BBC however the landscape of the
movie industry has significantly changed
since then with many major actors now
starring in one or more franchises this
shift makes Smith's reported involvement
in the greenlit sequel less surprising
what might have truly surprised fans
though is the possibility of his
collaboration with the younger movie
star Michael B Jordan according to
deadline goldsman found particular
interest in The Last of Us series
depiction of a world where humanity is
no longer the planet's dominant species
as well as in the multi-decade time Jump
while goldsman didn't divulge specific
details about the storyline for the I Am
Legend sequel he hinted at an
exploration of more of the idea
presented by Richard mat where
Humanity's reign as Earth's primary
rulers had ended as for Michael B
Jordan's role in the film goldsman
remained tight lipped leaving the
possibilities wide open while an obvious
path involves the two actors teaming up
Jordan's versatility demonstrated in his
portrayal of an antagonist and black
panther suggests the potential for him
to play one of the dark Seekers as well
how do you think your ancestors got
these you think they paid a fair price
while Richard mat's original depiction
of the dark seekers in his Nolla makes
them out to be unmistakable vampires the
film opted to diminish the vampire
element and instead depict the dark
Seekers as victims of a virus Neville's
Mission shifted from adapting to a world
overrun by the monsters to finding a
cure in viewing his story with the of
hope both the theatrical and alternate
endings feature Neville discovering a
cure however when the alternate ending
is considered canonical it Alters the
trajectory in this version Neville
doesn't heroically pass on his cure to
Anna to ensure the survival of future
Generations instead he abandons it all
together this raises an intriguing
question about the sequel what happens
with the Cure Neville discovered in the
Years following the events of the film
it's possible the writers will choose to
disregard the Cure as it may no longer
be relevant to the narrative but it
would be interesting to see how this
Factor complicates the relationship
between humans and dark Seekers as their
world continues to
evolve debates among fans about the
superiority of books versus their movie
adaptations are common often with each
medium having its proponents in the case
of I Am Legend however the consensus
leaned toward the book as the movie
arguably presents the story in a more
shallow manner favoring common Hollywood
TR hopes like a heroic self-sacrifice
for the greater good interestingly the
movie initially retained the theme of
change a prominent aspect of the book's
narrative however test audiences reacted
unfavorably to the original ending which
revealed Neville's fundamental mistake
this reaction was understandable given
the bleakness of that conclusion however
the Studio's decision to modify the
ending to aign more with mainstream
audience expectations resulted in the
removal of that core thematic element of
the book even symbolic motifs like the
recurring butterfly imagery are meant to
carry deep meaning Neville's daughter
making a butterfly sign before her death
and Anna's butterfly tattoo were
originally intended to symbolize the
dark seeker's Evolution from human
beings mirroring a butterfly's
transformation from a caterpillar the
alternate ending reinforces this theme
suggesting that future installments of
the story will delve deeper into not
only change but also the acceptance of
change
[Music]